the only thing i think i may love more
than elizabeth thornton on
one calls the heart is the elizabeth
that you play
and it was always you what a treat this
movie was and i know you have said
that this is one of your favorite things
you've ever done why is that
i loved loved the script the first time
i read it there was so much
heart uh so much focus on family and
love and discovering
your true sense your true sense of self
and following that path
well you opposite tyler hines
was truly chemistry for the ages
grandma makes reference to something
called the zing
you can't force zing and you can't deny
it
okay between the two of you is just the
perfect
push and pull what was it like working
with
tyler i don't think i could narrow it
down to one thing but i'll just say
you work with some people and it just
feels
very natural and like you've known that
person or have been working with them
for a long time and i think that was
the case between um between the two of
us
tyler is an incredible actor he's
very collaborative he's always wanting
to elevate the work
with him i actually requested him for
this movie because i thought he'd be so
great in this part
well i have to tell you there were so
many moments between the two of you
where
i was laughing all by myself on my couch
as i was watching the movie
oh my goodness yes it's like a solar
eclipse i can't look directly at it
were those real oysters that you were
eating in there in that moment
i don't like oysters but even for a
person who does enjoy oysters
i i have no idea how many oysters we had
to eat
um no it was the props department really
did an incredible job they created
this like gelatinous neutral tasting it
was
i want to say it was like jello and
coconut milk
with like maybe a dash of vanilla and
then tyler just squeezed
lemon juice all over them so the uh
expressions that certainly i was making
um were a reaction to just how tart they
were
were you actually eating key lime pie oh
that's something i was
definitely eating i was enjoying that so
much
there is of course a moment where
elizabeth gets a little
whipped cream on her mouth and um david
has to
wipe it off her and i think that was a
moment where i
just lost it and i i really could not
control the giggles
it's so interesting you bring that up
because i thought about that as i was
watching it i said how does she take the
perfect
bite to just get a little bit right
there
is there is there no perfect science to
this tyler kept saying things like you
know just
throw it in the corner of your mouth and
i'm like you do it then it's right in
the corner of your mouth
i sort of built a little hill of whipped
cream on the fork so that when i took a
bite it just
this is more information than you need
but it was just naturally there we love
the behind the scenes of movie magic so
i appreciate you sharing
your strategy
[Music]
let's go i want to talk about the final
scene
it was so magical to watch and it really
reminded me a lot of the rom-coms that
i grew up loving um the twinkly lights
the slow dancing the meaningful
words exchanged between the characters
bring me back to that final scene and
why you think
it's it's truly so special there was
something really magical about that
scene wasn't there
i think so much of it is in tyler's
performance of that
final speech almost all of the movie
he's really not pursuing elizabeth
because he's being respectful of his
brother
um so in that moment where we finally
get to see him
open up and be vulnerable and share how
he really feels with her it's
just so tender and romantic the ambiance
of the wedding in the background the
music playing
the slow dance it's just it's all
leading up to this
magical homework moment well the the
magic i said between you and tyler it's
very very real
are there plans to collaborate again and
maybe co-star
in another project together again i
would love it so much um i'm
already trying to convince everyone that
we need to shoot the sequel
yes make this eyes please yes right
but i also i just think that i've found
a great collaborator in tyler and we
really like working together so yeah
hopefully there will be
more projects in our future we've got to
make
christmas in a room